[Music]
good evening it's good to see everyone
again
this evenings message is called stones
of fire sons and daughters of the Living
God and we're going to pick up and go a
little bit farther from where we did
last night I know in our earlier
messages we have really spent a lot of
time focusing on the negative on the
darkness
these last two messages we're focusing
on the light we want to expose error but
if all we do is expose error and
everybody goes home you've got head
knowledge but if we show light from
God's Word when you leave here with that
that will change lives that's what's
most important so what I want to do is
open with me to a text in Romans chapter
8 Romans chapter 8 and we're going to
read verse 19 and I'm going to
paraphrase I'm gonna translate using the
original Greek so if you're reading a
King James which I have that's the only
thing I read don't be worried and think
I'm you know using some corrupt version
Romans chapter 8 verse 19 for the
earnest expectation of all creation is
waiting for the manifestation of the
sons and daughters of God in the Greek
when you look up the word sons it means
children begotten and you can be a male
or female and be a child right
so when you see sons of God realize when
this was written and why that that word
was used this is including men and women
and it says that all of creation the
entire universe is waiting for this one
event for this one event they're
watching this planet to see what God can
do and God says that his glory is not in
taking a mighty man and making him more
mighty God's glory is in taking the
weakest and doing the impossible through
them and I'm going to give you a quick
example of that
do you remember Abraham before God
changed his name Abram and often I've
wondered about that you know why the
change of a name because name was a
symbol of character and we know that
Abraham is known as the father of faith
the father of faith so when you when you
read that his name was Abram I looked it
up one time and the word Abram the name
Abram
literally means a mighty father like a
governor you can be the head of a tribe
and not have any children you can be the
head of a clan if you're in Scotland or
Ireland and you don't have any children
but they still call you father because
you're the head does that make sense
Abraham's name meant a mighty father he
was a man that was strong he was a
warrior when he had to defend his family
he was wealthy he was very gifted but he
did not have any children and one day
God came to him and said I'm gonna
change your name today an apron knew
that years before God had made a promise
to him that he was going to give him a
son and years had passed by and he still
had no child and you can imagine what
that was like for his wife Sarah so God
is talking to Abram there alone one day
and he tells him I'm changing your name
so Abram knew this was a big event and
he waited
and God said your name will not be Abram
anymore but ah bruh Homme or Abraham for
I am making you a father of a great
multitude now this is not recorded in
the Bible but when I use my mind in a
sanctified imagination I imagine what it
must have been like for Abraham when he
gets back to camp that day you know do I
tell everybody do I not tell everybody I
mean you know what am I supposed to do
and and he probably couldn't withhold
the information from his dear wife so
you know in my mind I think you know
okay well maybe he was nervous about
making a huge statement to everybody but
he went to his wife and said and this is
a parable he went to his wife and said
honey guess what happened today when I
was praying to the Lord and I went to
offer sacrifice and she's like what dear
and he told her God changed my name and
she said what did he change it to
Abraham and she went a father of a great
multitude that was confirmation of the
promise that God had made previously to
him and he knew they were at the point
where they needed that confirmation just
like when my wife was struggling with me
being gone from home God gave her a
confirmation one day because he knew her
faith was was getting weak and she
needed that now we're still in the
parable Abram goes to work that week and
a few days later a man comes in on a
camel and the camel is is stumbling into
the camp it had it hasn't had any water
any food in days the man on its back is
slumped over almost dead he has been
without water and food for days and
Abraham pulls him down off new is his
camel he tells the servants take the
camel
get it water get it food and he sets the
men down and tells the servants go get
water for him and make a meal for him
and and Abram gets a basin and he's
washing his feet and washing his head
and and helping the man and the man gets
the food and he's looking around and
he's he's surprised and he's overjoyed
but he has to eat because it's been days
since he's had anything and the man's
eating and after he finally relaxes he
looks at Abram Abraham and he says I
can't thank you enough my name is John
what's your name uh-oh what does he say
now think about this for a moment if you
were Abraham if I tell him my name is
Abram I'm denying what God has promised
but if I tell him my name is Abraham
he's gonna ask me where's all your
children and then I look really foolish
you want to talk about a walk of faith
because Abraham from the day that God
named him he told everyone my name is
Abraham and if they asked where is your
children he said they're on the way
because God has promised and he cannot
lie amen now let me show you why that
matters for the spirit itself beareth
witness with our spirit in our minds
that we are the children of God and if
we are children then we are heirs heirs
of God and joint-heirs with Christ let
me ask you a question what do you think
Jesus is waiting to inherit
us that's the only thing left he's
waiting to inherit the Bible says we are
his inheritance do you know what he said
in in the Gospel of John he actually
said before Calvary he told the
disciples he said the Prince of this
world is coming but he has nothing in me
he has no rights to me and then a little
while later he said now is the Prince of
this world cast out and I if I be lifted
up I will draw all men unto me people
will still think that Satan is running
this world what do you think Jesus said
in Matthew 28 all power in heaven and
earth has now been given to me go
proclaim the glad tidings
that's why Christians are standing on
that little piece of ground and they're
trembling they don't realize that Christ
is king they think for some reason that
he's still struggling with overcoming
he's just waiting on us to take hold of
his promises because you can't find the
disciples trembling in fear after the
Holy Spirit fell upon them on the day of
Pentecost they were afraid before that
day but after that day they went boldly
it didn't matter if it was the seizure
or if it was the Pope in Rome it made no
difference they had no longer any fear
Jesus is not waiting to inherit anything
except you and I now listen to what he
says here in first John beloved now are
we the sons and daughters of God and it
does not appear what we shall be but we
know not we guess we think we hope we
know
that when he appears we shall be like
him do you know what Jesus said in the
Gospel of John I believe it was John he
said be therefore perfect even as your
father in heaven is perfect we quoted
this the other night do you remember and
do you remember what sister white said
this command is a promise be ye
therefore perfect even as your father in
heaven is perfect
jesus also said it is written be ye holy
for I am holy and the Apostle Paul was
inspired to write if the firstfruits is
holy then the whole lump is holy and you
think yeah but I'm not holy I had one
brother that asked me one day he said
this can't be true that you're telling
me that that Jesus did it all for me
because if he did how come I still
sinned yesterday and I asked him I said
and I was praying I was like Lord helped
me I looked at him and I said if you
know that you died in Christ and that
you are now dead unto sin why did you
fall yesterday he was standing on the
dark side of the cross looking forward
waiting for something to take place
sister white said we are to stand on the
sunny side of the Cross knowing what was
finished at Calvary and claiming it as
our own how can I continue to sin
knowing that I died I'll never forget
the day I'll never forget the day that I
I was calling out to a man for help and
we may have talked about this but I was
calling out for help and I could not get
victory over a certain sin in my life
and I called this me
and I found him he had written an
article online that really inspired me
with hope and I called this older
gentleman and I said I need help and he
said what's wrong and I told him and he
said Eric you know what's wrong with you
and I said what he said you're still
very much alive and I thought you know
that's ignorant of course I'm alive he
said no he said you don't understand I
said you're right I don't understand
he said you're still very much alive
that's why sin still has a hold on you
and I said I don't understand he said
let me give you an example
he said let's say that I send you to
this fancy the fanciest hotel in Fresno
five hundred dollars a night for the
rooms I send you there to pick up a
package for me that's in the lobby you
got to wait in the lobby so you go in
and you sit down there and one of those
lobby chairs and while you're sitting
there you didn't realize they were
having the Miss America pageant at that
hotel at the conference center so you're
sitting there and all of a sudden these
20 or 30 women come walking through in
their bathing suits he said what happens
to you and I said oh man there's a
battle I'm trying to look at the floor
and I'm looking at the floor and my mind
is still going I'm not gonna look at
that I wonder what color that bathing
suit was that just walked by that I'm
not gonna look at that was the struggle
I was dealing with as a man and I could
not seem to get the victory over it and
he told me he said your pulse rates
probably going up he said you've got
blood that's circulating on the surface
of the skin
he said you're battling I said yes I'm
battling he said are you winning I said
I'm not looking he said but you're
thinking about it Jesus said if you've
looked
and desired you've already committed
adultery in your heart and I said that I
said there you go
that's what's wrong I said I have been
battling for 35 years and I still don't
have the victory I said and I can't seem
to get it he said it's because you're
still alive he said now he said I'm
going to bring he said I'm gonna go down
to the hospital I'm gonna go into the
morgue there was a man that died there a
week ago they've still got him because
something came up
with the funeral arrangements he's been
dead for a week I'm gonna go win I'm
gonna get his body I'm gonna put it on a
stretcher put it in an ambulance
I bring the body down to the hotel room
I wheel him in on a stretcher I pick him
up and I'm setting this corpse down
right next to you on that seat he said
now rewind those 20 or 30 young ladies
all come walking through and their
bathing suits and bikinis and he says
you're on your face battling he said
what's happening to the dead man
I said nothing he said that's exactly
right he said you don't realize that you
died with Christ you're still very much
alive he said the only way you will ever
get victory is if you count Christ's
death as your own that's why the Apostle
Paul says reckon ye also yourselves to
be dead indeed unto sin but alive unto
God amen
John chapter 3 very familiar story
Nicodemus he was a very righteous man by
the letter of the law he was not one of
the Pharisees it was cheating on his
wife for cheating on his temple tax or
or eating pork when nobody was looking
Nicodemus was an upright man by man
standards but yet he came to Jesus that
night alone and he was older than Jesus
Jesus was a young man that's why
Nicodemus couldn't come see him during
the daytime Jesus had just turned 30
years old when his ministry began you
weren't even considered a ban until 30
so Nicodemus here and I don't know how
old he was but just probably guessing
you know 50 60 maybe 70 he was an elder
very respected member of the Sanhedrin
he comes to Jesus and he tells Jesus in
John chapter 3 verse 1 and 2 he says we
know that you are from God we know you
came from God because no man can do the
miracles that we see you doing except
God be with him that means in him
Emmanuel Jesus looked at Nicodemus and
he knew what the question was same
question I was I'm going to church I'm
doing this I'm doing this I'm a vegan
I'm I'm doing all the right things but
something is still missing
and Jesus knew something was missing the
Nicodemus is life and Jesus looked at
Nicodemus and he said Marvel not that I
say unto you you must be born again it's
not optional the born-again experience
it's not like well I'll do that if I get
a chance if you're not born again you'll
never see the kingdom of heaven jesus
said so
the next question that came out of
nicodemus mouth was how is this possible
can an old man like me in her back into
his mother's womb and when I read that
the same thought went through my mind
how how does that happen
that's what I want Jesus and I'm there
at the house by myself and I look up
into heaven and I'm like how I really I
have no pride anymore how does this
happen
and you know a thought came to my mind
and I know it was God that brought it to
my mind Jesus wasn't mocking Nicodemus
he wasn't making fun of Nicodemus you
know I mean that's not even in Christ's
character because Jesus asked Nicodemus
he said are you not a master a PhD and
Israel aren't you the one that teaches
not only Sabbath School but you're a
church leader and you don't understand
these things the only way that Jesus
could ask Nicodemus that question is if
somewhere in the Old Testament the
born-again experience had already been
revealed I've never thought about that
before I always thought you know born
again that's New Testament he wouldn't
have asked Nicodemus if Nicodemus
couldn't have known and I looked at the
Lord I said Lord Wow show me where this
is I want to show you this is important
make a note of this it's in Galatians
and it's so clear I thought I can't
believe I've missed this Galatians
chapter 4 Paul here is is trying to help
God's children to understand the
difference between achieving eternal
life and righteousness by their own
works and achieving it by faith
living faith faith that works by love
but faith in Christ Jesus and listen to
what he says he says tell me verse 21
you that desire to be under the law do
you not hear what the law says for it is
written that Abraham had two sons the
one or first by a bondmaid a slave and
the other the second son by a freewoman
he'd and I'm paraphrasing this he that
was born of the bondwoman or slave was
born after or by the flesh but he that
was born of the free woman was by
promise God made a promise to Abraham
and Sarah Isaac didn't come because of
Abraham and Sarah figuring out some
special kind of herb or a special way to
do certain things or doing a yoga class
or Isaac came because God had made a
promise and he cannot lie now look over
at verse 28 now we brethren as Isaac was
our children of promise and the word of
there is also by we are children by
promise I promise that's how a person is
begotten again now I want to show you
what the other side says with the dark
side Deepak Chopra we talked about him
the other night
he said in reality we are divinity in
disguise and the gods and goddesses in
embryo that are contained within us seek
to be fully materialized there's a quote
from the Shaolin grandmasters textbook
says the dragon dwells deep inside of
every person waiting for the person to
give them permission to come out I don't
believe that the devil only abides in
the hearts of those that refuse to allow
Christ to come in and take possession
John Stephens we looked at this earlier
he said martial ways are spiritual
disciplines to be practiced for the sake
of enlightenment and this enlightening
is what the occult world and what the
Eastern mystical world it's what they
all say being born again is being
enlightened through certain techniques
through saying mantras through spiritual
exercises they say that's what happens
to have this change that they call the
born-again experience this is a quote
from Marcus J Borg before he passed away
listen to what he writes and this is an
image from a Catholic Encyclopedia you
have Jesus on the left-hand side you
know he's the Catholic Jesus because he
has those two fingers crossed that means
I'm king and priest that's what the Pope
claims to be king and priest if you look
on the left hand side that is the Buddha
that the Catholic Encyclopedia actually
talks about the Buddha and they made him
a saint many years ago they called him
Saint Joseph at and they list him they
say this is the Buddha in their
encyclopedia they sainted him one of the
popes did he says enlightenment as an
archaeal religious metaphor belongs to a
mystical way of being religious outside
of the Jewish and
in traditions the best-known
enlightenment experience is the Buddha's
mystical experience this is from a
previous pastor this is one of the men
that all the spiritual formation leaders
and teachers looked up to and trained
under such an experience leads to seeing
everything differently it's not simply
an intellectual or mental seeing as when
you say oh I see what you mean rather
enlightenment as a religious experience
involves communion or union with what is
an immediate knowing of the sacred now
as funny he uses the word Union and he
uses the word communion right before it
that should give us a hint when we take
communion the Lord's Supper it's
becoming one with Christ that's why the
Apostle Paul tells us that if we do so
unworthily we're eating and drinking
damnation to ourselves if I take
communion without faith that Christ not
only died but rose again all I'm left
with is his death and Paul says for that
reason many in our churches are sick
have disease and many sleep they're
eating and drinking but they're only
partaking of the death they don't have
living faith in the resurrection he says
this type of enlightenment this is what
he calls the born-again experience Ellen
White says through hedonism Satan had
for ages turned men away from God but he
won his great triumph in perverting the
faith of Israel by contemplating and
worshiping their own conceptions that he
then had lost a knowledge of God
have become more and more corrupt the
principle that man can save himself by
his own works lay at the foundation of
every heathen religion that's what the
Buddhists do the Hindus the Muslims you
name it
now unfortunately she says so it was
with Israel so it is with most
Christians that are alive today they are
striving through their own works and
they don't have any comprehension of
what the born-again experience really is
many people go they go into the
baptismal pool and they come up and they
go it was a symbol they don't realize
that when they went under that water
they literally died with Christ
it's a proclamation that I believe I'm
dead and I do not live anymore and when
I rise I rise with him to walk in
newness of life
first Peter chapter 1 verse 1 through 3
I'm sorry chapter 1 verse 3 through 9 he
tells us blessed be or praise be the God
and father of our Lord Jesus Christ
which according to his abundant mercy
hath begotten us again unto a Living
Hope a living assurance by the
resurrection of Jesus Christ from the
dead when I read that I was like alright
Lord you're telling me I have to be born
again but here you're telling me that
God according to his abundant mercy hath
begotten us again unto a Living Hope by
resurrection of Jesus Christ from the
dead I was like is this something still
yet to be achieved or is it something I
am supposed to take hold of by faith
Peter goes on and says whom having not
seen you love and in whom you remember
we talked about that in Ephesians in
Christ in him in whom it says in whom
though now you see him not yet believing
he rejoice with joy unspeakable and full
of glory receiving the end or the result
of your faith even the salvation of your
souls now I want to share something with
you right here this is important of
everything we've talked about this week
this is the most important thing that
I'm going to share in whom in whom when
you go to Ephesians chapter 1 there's a
promise given there in verse 4 actually
reverse three and four Ephesians chapter
one it says blessed be the God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ and
that's funny because that's how that's
how Peter says same exact opening the
word blessed means praise be praise be
to the God and the father of our Lord
Jesus Christ who hath is hath future
it's past it's done who hath blessed us
with all spiritual blessings in heavenly
the word places is supplied by the
translators you'll see it's italicized
in the King James when you look that up
it's
says hath blessed us with all spiritual
blessings in the heavens in Christ
according as he hath chosen us in him
before the foundation of the world that
we should be holy and without blame
before him in love and I read that verse
one day when I was sitting at home and I
said Lord that says you chose me in
Christ before the foundation of the
world and then the Apostle Paul goes on
in Philippians 3 verse 9 and it says I
pray that we might be found in him not
having our own righteousness which is by
the law but the righteousness which is
by the faith of Jesus Christ and I said
I found the key to the gospel it's being
in him and I was so excited I'm M there
at the house by myself and my wife's at
school children at school and I was like
this is the key after all these years
I'm 48 years old I'm like why didn't I
see this when I was 10 the whole key to
the entire gospel is being found in him
and then you know what happened a
question came to my mind how do I get in
him and I looked up and and I know God
laughs at me I know he does I mean you
know like a father would laugh at a
child and I know Jesus was like dad
watch this I mean think about that the
Bible says Christ is our elder brother
and he's there and he's thinking oh this
is beautiful
his eyes are being opened and I looked
up and I said Lord thank you for showing
me this key
how do I get in Jesus and you know our
God he has got a sense of humor do you
know what he said to me I heard him just
as clear as day you know he speaks in
your heart you can't you can't explain
that to somebody else but you know when
God talks to you God spoke to me
I heard him just as clear as day and he
said Eric how did you get in your mom
how did you and I thought this is the
Adiemus all over again God said how did
you get in your mother's womb and I
looked up and I laughed at I said God I
didn't have anything to do with that he
said huh Eric how did you get in your
father's loins to get put in your
mother's womb and I paused and I looked
up and I said God I didn't have anything
to do with that and he smiled and he
said now you're beginning to understand
love and mercy and I said Lord I believe
you but I need a verse because I could
never share this with someone just
because I know you're telling me but I
need a verse turn with me to first
Corinthians chapter 1 1st Corinthians
chapter 1 verse 29 through 31 listen to
what it says God is so beautiful he
spoke in my heart and I asked him
chapter 1 verse 29 through 31 of 1st
Corinthians I asked him for confirmation
in his word and he showed me I mean
within moments he showed me he said seek
and you shall find knock and it shall be
opened unto you ask and I will answer
you will receive so I started flipping
the pages and I had to I had to verse
underlined listen to what he says verse
29 so that no flesh should glory in my
presence for of him God are you in
Christ Jesus who of or by God is made
unto us wisdom and righteousness and
sanctification and redemption
so that according as it is written he
that glorieth let him glory in the Lord
God put us in Christ Jesus and he chose
us in him before the foundation of the
world I can't put myself back in Christ
it was done and people say yeah but what
about those that are lost where's your
focus where is your focus one lady wrote
to Ellen White and she said yeah but
yeah but yeah but and you would Ellen
White told her she wrote back to her and
she said you know what she said the Lord
revealed to me when you're walking
through the pages of his word she said
all you're finding are the thorns she
said I encourage you to spend an hour a
day looking for the pinks and the Roses
stop focusing on the negative focus on
the promise if God be for us who can be
against us he that spared not his own
son but delivered him up for us all how
shall he not with him also freely give
us all things amen
God said I put you there now walk by
faith in it
first Peter one whom having not seen
speaking of Christ you love and whom
though now you see him not yet believing
you rejoice with joy unspeakable and
full of glory receiving the end of your
faith even the salvation and freedom of
your souls
Isaiah it's not just New Testament
Isaiah 45 verse 22 through 25 the Lord
says look unto me and be ye saved
he doesn't say strive to be try to be
hope to be he says be just like he says
be holy for I am holy he says I am the
Lord I speak righteousness and I asked
the Lord one day I said Lord what does
that look like
you speak righteousness I said I don't
mean to push you but show me so that I
can see it and you know what the Lord
did he took me right to Luke chapter 5
there was a leper that came to Jesus and
that leper and I'm going to tell you in
a parable form that means I'm adding
some thoughts that might have happened
could have happened makes sense that it
happened but it's not there in the Bible
okay so bear with me
sanctified imagination this leper comes
to Jesus throws himself on the ground
and you know everybody else fled because
he had HIV it was the same thing
do you understand incurable and
contagious as far as to the max he
throws himself on the ground after
everybody has fled knowing he could be
put to death even for being there and he
cast himself on the ground and he says
David have mercy on me well first thing
son of David means I'm saying you're
king you're the one that was promised
would come your king I know you can do
anything and she's just looked at him
and said son you're a mess I mean you've
got like leprosy and the man said I know
and Jesus said have you been to the
hospital
the man said they said I was incurable I
mean it's incurable this disease can't
be cured there's no medicine I'm
incurable and Jesus said have you been
to the church have you been to the
seventh-day Adventist Church there's one
right down the road and the man said
yeah I went there but they quoted
scripture to me they told me as a man so
so Shelly read you know how the devil
does that sometimes you made your bed
lie in it you know what God's Word says
in Hosea 13 he says o Israel thou hast
destroy'd thyself but in me is thine
help I will be thy king 4 where is any
other that may save thee in all of thy
cities this man looked at Jesus and he
said I know if thou wilt thou canst make
me clean you know what Jesus said I will
be thou clean John chapter 15 verse 3
jesus said now today you are clean
through the word which I am speaking
unto you today you don't have to wait
you don't have to be on probation for
six weeks there's no amount of time that
will wash away your past even if that
was yesterday or this afternoon you've
got to take hold of his word and say
it's mine now in this moment
look unto me and be ye saved all the
ends of the earth for I am God that's
the same God that called the light out
of darkness he said let there be light
and there was I have sworn by myself
yea the word has gone out of my mouth
and righteousness and shall not return
unto me void surely shall they say in
the Lord have I righteousness and
strength even to him shall all men come
and all those that are incensed and
angry against him will be ashamed for in
the Lord shall all the seed and children
of Israel be justified and shall glory
now you ask yourself how can I be in
Christ there was an article and I'm
gonna make this very short I don't want
to run out of time there was a sermon
that was preached by a man named WW
Prescott he preached it at the 1895 camp
meeting in Australia he preached over 30
messages at that one camp meeting if you
would like me to send you the message
that I'm about to share with you I'll
send it to you by email he brought
something out I'd never seen before
and I'm not gonna read it but I just
want to give you the reference it's in
Hebrews chapter I believe chapter 6 or 7
let me just make sure Hebrews chapter 7
the first 10 first 10 or 12 verses it
actually says that when Abraham was
paying tithes to Melchizedek that Levi
who was his great grandson was in
Abraham paying tithes to
Melchizedek and Levi hadn't even been
born yet did you ever notice that before
do you know that when Adam sinned every
single one of us was in him physically
when I met my wife 25 26 years ago my
son and my daughter were inside of me
when I met her I didn't even have any
intention of having children that
scientific that's that science they know
that my children were inside of me that
little whatever that was that little DNA
and that genetic blueprint it went out
of me when my wife and I became one and
God between the union of a husband and a
wife he took that blueprint and he made
it into flesh my children were in me you
were in Adam when he fell that's why the
Bible says we were born with the
sentence of death already on us people
will tell me no you're a sinner because
of what you do well then how come babies
die at 3 days old or at 1 day old
they die because the sentence of death
was already on them that's why Christ
became the second and last Adam Ellen
White says he took the first Adam's
place as head of the human race Adam
came from Christ so Christ was the only
one that could stand in Adam's place
when you look at what happened there in
Hebrews Levi was in Abraham when Abraham
was paying tithe and Paul says though
the writer of Hebrews says that Levi was
paying tithes in Abraham even though he
had been born
yet do you know what that means that
means that if you are in Christ because
you believe what God says he already
said he chose you in him before the
foundation of the world then that means
you were in him when he was winning
every victory and you were in him when
he was dying on Calvary and you were
into him when he was being raised from
the grave
and you were in him when he was set down
on the throne on high why do you think
Paul says we are seated with Christ in
the heavens how can we be there if we're
still here we're in him now listen to
what the servant of the Lord says after
Jesus was after Jesus had been baptized
by John in Jordan he went straight way
up out of the water to the bank of the
river and he bowed in the attitude of
prayer he here identifies himself with
sinners as our representative in taking
upon him our sins and numbering himself
with transgressors in his prayer Christ
with his human arm his human nature in
circles fallen humanity while with his
divine arm he is reaching for the throne
of the infinite his hands were raised
upward and his eyes were fixed as if
penetrating heaven and he poured out his
soul in supplication to his father for
strength to meet our unbelief and
sinfulness and I'm paraphrasing that do
you see
remember when you read you have to read
this as it's spoken to you individually
otherwise God's Word and promises won't
have any power he pled for power to
break the power of Satan over man and to
be able to overcome Satan in behalf of
man he presented humanity before his
father asking that he would grant to
fallen man the light and strength and
power from his own throne to
successfully overcome the Prince of the
power of darkness never had angels
listened to such a prayer they were
solicitous ready and willing and eager
to bear to the praying Redeemer messages
of assurance and love but no the father
himself will minister to his son direct
from the throne preceded the light of
the glory of God the heavens were opened
and beams of light and glory proceeded
there from the people stood spellbound
with fear and amazement their eyes were
fastened upon Christ whose bow form was
bathed in the beautiful light and glory
that ever surround the throne of God his
upturned face was glorified as they had
never before seen the face of man the
thunders rolled and the lightnings
flashed from the opening heavens and a
voice came there from in terrible
Majesty saying this is my beloved Son in
whom I am well pleased that quote is
from youth instructor March 1 1874 now
let me read the next statement to you
this is desire of Ages page 112 - 113
and the word that was spoken to Jesus at
the Jordan
this is my beloved son in whom I am
well-pleased embraces all humanity God
spoke to Jesus as our representative
with all of our sins and weaknesses we
are not cast aside as worthless for he
hath made us accepted in the beloved the
glory that rested upon Christ is a
pledge of the love of God for us the
light which fell from the open portals
of heaven upon the head of our Savior
will fall upon us as we pray for help to
resist temptation the voice which spoke
to Jesus says to every believing soul
this is my beloved child in whom I am
well pleased
do you understand what we just saw and
read we were in Christ when he was
baptized you go through Ellen White's
writings and type in Holy Spirit read
everything you can find from her and
remember something God was revealing
more and more light to her as she got
older it wasn't like she was given all
the light in 1844 and boom it stopped
there was times in 1888 after she heard
EJ Wagner share about the two covenants
she wrote she said we may have been
wrong in our understanding of the
covenants until I heard what Wagner's
presented she said I had never even
considered the two covenants the way he
presented it she said we may have been
wrong
this is important we were in Christ that
means when we asked the Father for the
gift of his Spirit we already have
Christ's righteousness as the assurance
we will receive if we abide in him
do you remember what Jesus said in John
15 verse 7 abide in me and you think
what do you have to do to abide in a
house well you have to be put there
first if I'm on the outside of the house
and somebody says abide in there and I
go in where well in the house but I've
never been in there before I don't know
what it looks like in there you can't
abide somewhere unless you have already
been put there it means stay in me when
Christ was baptized Ellen White says and
the scripture says you were in him being
baptized when we go down into the water
now when we give our lives to the Lord
it is a symbol it is saying Lord I
believe that I was in him back there
2,000 years ago not only was I baptized
but when Christ won the victory Ellen
White says so few seventh-day Adventists
have any understanding of what took
place in the wilderness of temptation
they don't make what happened to Christ
their own the Bible says thanks be to
God which giveth us the victory when did
he give us the victory we are more than
conquerors through him that loves us
Christ is our victory our righteousness
our wisdom our justification our
glorification it's all him
and as we realize that our hearts are
broken pride is expelled and there's a
love that is given to us that nothing
can extinguish Ellen White says it's
love that begets love not fear so when
you are looking at your son or your
daughter or your wife or the drunkard on
the street or the girl that just got
caught and she's had an abortion or
whatever you've got to say God loves you
he chose you in Christ Jesus before the
foundation of the world amen
[Music]